no bernie wasn't supposed to be i know
he wasn't yeah yeah it was it was the
internet
which is why barack obama is so scared
of the internet right now oh tell me
about that
this is that is a great tim tool segway
that was you have a musical queue
what what what a coincidence we have an
article about this
obama said the internet is quote
the single biggest threat to our
democracy
why because people were sharing memes
of pepe the frog and then they voted for
donald trump i think i see
a perspective of what he might have met
that corporate power
is the most that's right and like i
think that's why barack obama met
corporate power i don't know
i know i do know maybe he met like
twitter being able to ban whoever they
want
because it seems like a very vague
statement i want to know the greater are
you being ironic
no i'm just wondering what the greater
context the greater context actually is
not as nefarious as the headlines make
it out to be oh what's the concept
obama said now you have a situation in
which large swaths of the country
genuinely believe
that the democratic party let me be
clear let me be clear let me be clear
is a front i was born overseas for a
pedo ring
and he says i have a certificate of live
birth i was talking to a volunteer who's
going to door-to-door in philadelphia in
low-income african-american communities
and was getting serious ques
was getting questions about q and
conspiracy theories he was asked
is this new malevolent information
architecture bending the moral arc away
from justice he said i think it's the
biggest
threat to our democracy later in the
interview obama makes it quite clear
that much of his concern is specifically
about the internet
which he is also quite clear isn't going
away and the big platforms that sort of
dis
that sort and distribute most of the
internet for most people he said
i don't hold the tech companies entirely
responsible because this predates social
media
it was already there but social media
has turbocharged it
i know most of these folks i've talked
to them about it the degree to which
these companies are insisting that they
are more like a phone company than they
are like the atlantic i do not think
it's tenable i actually agree with that
this it's it's it's bunkering i agree
with him yeah
with you yeah they're making editorial
choices whether they've buried them in
algorithms or not
the first amendment doesn't require
private companies to provide a platform
for any view that is out there
at the end of the day we're going to
have to find a combination of government
regulations and corporate practices that
address this
because it's going to get worse if you
can penetrate crazy lies and conspiracy
theories just with texts imagine what
you can do when you can make it look
like you or me say anything on video and
we're pretty close to that now
goldberg says it's the famous steve
bennett strategy
flood the zone with human waste he swore
but you know we don't
he said if we do not have the capacity
to distinguish what's true from what's
false
then by definition the marketplace of
ideas doesn't work and by definition our
democracy doesn't work we are entering
into an uh epistle epistemological
epistemological crisis yeah so uh i
think it's amazing the idea that the
marketplace of ideas doesn't work
but having corporations and government
work together
to tell you what the truth is is really
a healthier alternative i know that's
not the academic definition of fascism
that all the elections like to use
no it's the that's the mussolini
mussolini invented fascists right right
right yeah
but the actual like now academic is
ultra nationalism
everything you know the individual is
sacrificed for this for the greater good
of the state
let me so but right the lucrative merger
of corporate something else
so mussolini there's an amazing book by
john diggins that came out in the 70s
called mussolini in america the
mussolini fascism view for america
before hitler mussolini was really
looked at
as this great great figure i talked
about this also and then you write
because you had the great depression uh
capitalism isn't work you don't want to
be like russia this was the third way
mussolini was regarded as the moderate
figure
um and fascism is based on a rejection
of reason
and it's about the will and the will to
power when obama says yes we can
that is quintessential fascism it's just
a fascism with a smile on its face and
that people like
but that is the idea it's like okay
mussolini how are you going to make the
railroads running time and you're going
to have this spending on military and
you're going to give her one job
we'll figure it out because we're
italians and we can do it
that is the fascist model now of course
the term has a very nefarious context
because you
got in bed with hitler and he's not
exactly a nice person but yeah it
it's always been part and parcel of um
american culture this is the crazy thing
about all the lockdowns right now
and what they're planning so you know
just going back to this stuff about
donald trump potentially winning
if you care about individual freedom if
you care about the right of the working
class if you care about wealth
inequality you do not want joe biden to
win this
but i i want to go back to what obama's
saying because this is something that's
a huge white pill
for me and i think for a lot of people
and in fact i tweeted about this
uh and i got more likes than the uh the
vox article about it
the point being they're scared because
people aren't looking at them as
arbiters of truth anymore right
they're telling you this is what's true
and a lot of people are saying well
whatever you say the opposite's true
yeah but then there's a lot of people
saying okay what's the alternative
let me hear the out the other side and
for a very long time
uh the left couldn't even handle fox
news existing
the fact that fox news is there and has
some kind of alternative to like
textbook npr atlantic new republic
uh chicanery was drove them crazy
and now fox news i mean they should be
so
thankful that it's just fox news because
things have gotten well not newsmax
and then oin and the internet and did
you see infowars
you see newsmax's ratings are they
through are they good through the roof
like 750
increase in the span of a week what
happened i never heard of them fox news
is doing a really really awful job
covering what's going on the election
now it's true there's people who want
confirmation bias but it's all it's also
true that i'm sitting there watching fox
news
and then they have john roberts say
there is no evidence of voter fraud and
i'm like what
what wasn't there tons of evidence
wasn't john roberts the one who was
talking about how everyone is
everyone needs to leave the media alone
stop picking on the media
the corporate press is factual but not
truthful there you go so
there is no evidence of voter fraud
we're not talking about a fraud
we're talking about lost votes right no
there's evidence of voter fraud okay but
he was just wrong oh okay so i'm trying
to i've tried to make him out to be
better than he is
they're playing semantic games they're
they're trying to replace the word
evidence with definitive proof
right they're also trying to make it
seem like the evidence that needs to be
presented to start an investigation is
like a videotape of somebody you know
carrying a balance no no no no not even
now
because that's not widespread you need
evidence of 7
000 a video of 7 000 people all going
we're switching votes for
biden we're switching votes for biden
singing a song and shuffling the push
broom
into a into a fire pit be a good skip
yeah it would be
that's that's what they expect there is
evidence i'll give you one
one example nashon garrett appeared on
laura ingram saying
he got a call from the voter integrity
fund they asked him if you requested an
absentee ballot in arizona he said no
did you vote no well someone did he said
that straight up on tv maybe he's lying
but that's still
evidence because the definition of
evidence is the available body of
information
suggesting something may be or signs or
indications that something may be
if someone comes out he's olympic he's
training for the olympics as a guy of
seeming uh
great repute and honor is saying that
wasn't me
i didn't do that okay we got evidence of
voter fraud is it systemic voter fraud
no but the way i put is like this
imagine you're walking down the street
and you're in you're you're in new york
city and there's a big building when all
of a sudden you hear a fire alarm going
off and you go oh geez a fire alarm
so you call 9-1-1 and they say 9-1-1
emergency response you go
there's a there's a fire alarm going off
i'm on fifth and you know and
a street or whatever and they go well do
you have
evidence there's a fire well the fire
alarm is going off i don't know i'm not
going in the building
well we don't have evidence of a
widespread fire in the building so we're
not going to bother investigating it all
right the alarm is going off that is
when the
fire department comes out goes in the
building walks out false alarm guys
someone just tripped the alarm we reset
it we're good to go or they go and say
wow there's a big
fire what's happening now is we have
sworn affidavits we have whistleblowers
we have massive irregularities we have
the voter integrity fund saying that
they found thousands of instances in
many different states
of people who have moved changed their
addresses and still voted and
now they're saying they found around
they did a random sampling
of around 1700 republicans asked them
did you request an absentee ballot about
500 said no
the remainder they said yes and they
sent it in but
around 450 uh they say never the mail
never
uh the voting system never received
their mail-in ballots
massive discrepancies so we got more
than this we've got smoke coming out of
the windows
and we've got the alarm going off and
they're telling us when we call 9-1-1
but that's not evidence of an actual
fire are you seeing the actual fire the
window there's a fire meanwhile
right if you go to wikipedia right now
and look up the entry for the 2016
election
the very first paragraph front in center
excuse me it's that pizza
it says there was evidence found that
russia tried to interfere in the
election
now what that means is yeah if i buy
five facebook ads
then i'm trying to interfere with the
election it's factual but not true
technically correct
yeah because like if you did it wouldn't
be like american
efforts well so if you were an american
it would they wouldn't say america is
trying to interfere they'd say michael
malus
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you